[Music]
you bring up this point of history you
know looking at these guys like george
washington yeah and it occurs to me too
when you look back on guys like
jefferson even that howling atheist to
quote his opponents
or or washington or you go further back
to christopher columbus
and you look through them yeah with
through a christian lens right
or what they're doing what it means for
civilization what it means for the
spreading of the gospel
in particular to say nothing of their
other virtues
you have a different outlook on them
than if you look back on these guys
through the lens of explicit marxism
which we're seeing today
through the lens of an understanding of
human nature that is totally at odds
with what our founders believed
and with what happens to be the truth
it's that religious view
whether it's the secular religious view
or other it's that religious view that
gives color
to these historical figures so is it any
surprise they tear down the statues
well you're right and that's the point
is that they
they stood for all of those things and
really we're talking about a war on the
west
yeah and a war on god
yeah i mean that that's what this is why
is all marxism
really atheistic marxism in others they
don't necessarily advertise that
but the point is there is no doubt that
you know that that all of these atheist
i mean all these marxist countries
were as viciously violently
atheist it's like out of a nightmare you
know
what they did to people of faith marx's
writings there's actually a good book
coming out by paul kanger but that's
we're plugging all these books we'll
plug paul's book it's called the devil
and karl marx
which goes into marx's writings some of
his poetry yeah so it's
good luck reading that stuff it's not
even just
explicitly atheist which it is it's
demonic
it's satanic it is let's not we don't
have all the time in the world let's cut
to the chase
that is correct okay and you need to
call these things what they are
we have not taught a
hatred of marxism and communism for the
last 50 years now
yeah my parents taught me to hate it why
because my mother grew up in germany
which became east germany
she saw it my father in greece the greek
civil war he saw the communists
they knew the deep wickedness
and the deceit of communism and they
taught me to understand
that this is not anodyne this is not
harmless
this is a a vicious enemy and
we now have enough young people in
america that never really got that
yeah and all they focuses on what's
wrong with with america and and i'm i'm
here to say that
black lives matter the organization and
that that whole thing and antifa
they are vicious
cultural marxist and their enemy
is the god of the bible i i talked about
uh in
in um in moby dick herman melville talks
about ahab who's like this demonic
figure he's he's animated by rage
what is this rage and at some point in
the book he says he wants to punch to
strike through the mask
of the sky he basically wants to kill
god
he's so angry and that rage that we see
on the radical left today it's that kind
of a rage there is not the beginning
of reasonableness anywhere to be found
it's a a destructive rage
and if we don't acknowledge that and
fight against it with
law and order and so on and so forth uh
we we
have no idea how bad things can get and
i think we need to begin to imagine
and we're getting some ideas this is the
key you can't divorce these things i
think a lot of people
look out and they see the statue
toppling and the blm and the crazy blue
hairs screaming on college campuses
and the the attacks on the churches they
see them all as
different phenomena they're not you
can't divorce those things
you got to focus on on each level of it